in the last video we saw the quotient
rule
the quotient rule which once again i
have mixed feelings about because it
really comes straight out of the product
rule if we have something of the form f
of x over g of x the derivative of it
could be this business right over here
so i thought i would at least do one
example where we can apply that and we
could use it do it to to find the
derivative of something useful
so what's the derivative what's the
derivative with respect to x let me
write this a little bit neater the
derivative with respect to x of tangent
of x
and you might say hey sal wait i thought
this was about the quotient rule but you
just have to remember what is the
definition of the tangent of x
well or what is one way to view the
tangent of x well tangent of x is the
same thing as
sine of x and let me now color code it
is the same thing as sine of x
sine of x
sine of x over cosine of x
over cosine
cosine of x
and now it makes it makes it it looks
clear that our expression is the ratio
or it's a kind of a it's it's one
function over another function so now we
can just apply the quotient rule so the
all of this business is going to be
equal to the derivative of sine of x
times cosine of x so what's the
derivative of sine of x
well that's just cosine of x so it's
cosine of x is derivative of sine of x
times whatever function we had in the
denominator so times cosine of x
cosine of x
minus
whatever function we had in the
numerator sine of x
sine of x
sine of x times the derivative of
whatever we have in the denominator well
what's the derivative of cosine of x
well the derivative of cosine of x is
negative sine of x so i'll put the sine
of x here and it's a negative so i can
just make this right over here a
positive and then all of that
all of that over
whatever was in the denominator squared
cosine
cosine of x
cosine of x squared now what does this
simplify to
well in the numerator right over here we
have cosine of x times cosine of x so
all of this simplifies to
cosine squared of x
and sine of x times sine of x that's
just sine
squared of x and what's cosine squared
of x plus sine squared of x this is one
of the most basic trigonometric
identities that comes straight out of
the unit circle definition of trig
functions cosine squared let me write it
over here cosine
squared of x plus sine
squared of x is equal to 1
is equal to 1 which simplifies things
quite nicely so cosine of square
cosine squared of x plus sine squared of
x all of this entire numerator is equal
to 1.
so this nicely simplifies
to
1 over
cosine of x squared which we could also
write like this cosine squared of x
these are two
ways of writing cosine of x squared
which is the same exact thing as 1 over
cosine of x
squared which is the same thing as
secant 1 over cosine of x is just secant
of x
secant of x squared or we could write it
like this secant squared of x and so
that's where it comes from if you know
that the derivative of sine of x is
cosine of x and the derivative of cosine
of x is negative sine of x we can use
the quotient rule which is once again
comes straight out of the product rule
to find the derivative of tangent x is
secant squared of x